There's nothing quite as unsatisfying as a
bad comedy.
An awful horror flick might provide some unexpected
laughs, and an atrocious action film might
have a few impressive stunts.
But watching someone who's supposed to be
funny and failing in every possible way is
just downright painful.
From pathetic sequels to ill-advised passion
projects, here are some of the cringeworthy
comedies that bombed with a zero rating on
Rotten Tomatoes.
True Memoirs of an International Assassin
If you visit Kevin James' page on Rotten Tomatoes,
you'll see a lot of green splotches.
But if you're looking for the ultimate Kevin
James calamity, then head over to Netflix
and check out True Memoirs of an International
Assassin, the worst-reviewed film of the comedian's
career.
This 2016 film follows James as a schlubby
writer who pens a bestselling novel about
an international assassin.
Unfortunately, his publisher is marketing
the book as nonfiction, so everybody thinks
James is a real-life assassin.
As a result, he's kidnapped and taken to Venezuela,
where he finds himself in the middle of a
deadly game involving South American revolutionaries
and a Russian gangster.
"I punched you.
You punch like a small child.
It hurt you.
It tickled."
Honestly, it's not a bad premise, but the
execution is completely lackluster.
The A.V.
Club described the film as "a poor man's Edgar
Wright movie," while RogerEbert.com noted
that it keeps using the same gags over and
over.
"Never bring a knife AAAAAAAHHHHHH!
You brought a knife to a gunfight!"
All Nighter
The 2017 film All Nighter finds J.K. Simmons
playing an ultra-manly dad whose daughter
has disappeared, so he teams up with her ex-boyfriend,
a banjo-loving hippie played by Emile Hirsch.
As they look for her, they encounter a whole
host of bizarre characters while Simmons teaches
Hirsch how to be a real "man."
Aside from its very specific views on manhood,
critics agreed the movie suffers from some
shoddy directing and a weak script.
"A man should know how to drive.
I have a bicycle.
Well, congrats on that.
It's actually considered very masculine in
the Netherlands"
As Derek Smith of Slant Magazine put it, All
Nighter jumps back and forth from "mystery"
to "mismatched-buddy movie" to "inspirational
redemptive drama," and sadly, it can't stick
any of its landings.
Still, Simmons does his best to get audiences
laughing, because slump or no slump, the man
is always a pro.
The Con Is On
The Con Is On boasts a pretty incredible cast
led by Uma Thurman, Tim Roth, Alice Eve and
Sofia Vergara.
The plot revolves around Thurman as a con
artist who owes money to a dangerous kingpin,
so she decides to steal a priceless jewel
from her alcoholic husband's ex-wife.
But it just can't compare to better heist
films, as it relies on "edgy" humor that really
isn't all that edgy.
"You haven't ---- me."
That impressive cast actually weighs the movie
down, as the characters are just loud, eccentric,
and lacking any real human elements.
So while it's always nice to see Uma Thurman
in action, it's hard not to wish this particular
film wasn't trying to con audiences into wasting
an hour and 30 minutes of their time watching
it.
Surfer, Dude
2008's Surfer, Dude was a bit of a passion
project for Matthew McConaughey, as it combined
catching waves, smoking weed, and walking
around without a shirt on.
The plot, very predictably, involves a stoned
surfer who just wants to enjoy the ocean.
"Not feeling it.
. Not into it.
I just wanna surf.
Beat the stove day to day."
Unfortunately, Mother Nature and the Man are
getting in the way, so McConaughey fights
back with the power of pot.
And as this movie co-stars Woody Harrelson
and Willie Nelson, there's a whole lot of
ganja going on.
Sadly, it was a complete wipeout with the
critics, but fortunately, The Lincoln Lawyer
came along in 2011 and saved McConaughey's
career, leaving Surfer, Dude adrift in the
sea of bad Hollywood comedies.
Look Who's Talking Now
John Travolta's career has seen some incredible
highs and some embarrassing lows, but he arguably
hit rock bottom with Look Who's Talking Now,
the final installment in the Look Who's Talking
trilogy.
The series got started in 1989, with Travolta
playing a cab driver who falls in love with
a single mom played by Kirstie Alley, who
has a talking baby that sounds like Bruce
Willis.
In the sequel, Alley and Travolta have a daughter
who sounds like Roseanne Barr.
In part three, we meet two bickering dogs
voiced by Danny DeVito and Diane Keaton, who
eventually fall in love.
Multiple critics slammed the movie as a ripoff
of Lady and the Tramp.
But instead of of romantic spaghetti dinners,
Look Who's Talking Now is loaded with lousy
quips, poop jokes, and lines that feel a little
out of place in a kid's film.
"It's Daphneeee, you tick magnet.
Tick magnet?
Like you've never sniffed a butt."
The movie also desperately tries to pad out
its running time with jaw-droppingly bad fantasy
sequences, one of which features a pointless
Charles Barkley cameo.
"Can I play?
With me?
Let's get busy."
Homer and Eddie
Starring James Belushi and Whoopi Goldberg,
1989's Homer and Eddie has largely been forgotten
by comedy fans, and that's probably because
it just isn't funny.
Sure, it tries to be, but it also wants to
be a heavy-handed drama.
And while that convergence of tears and laughter
might work for some films, here it results
in disaster.
The movie follows a mentally challenged man
named Homer who wants to visit his long-lost
parents, so he decides to hitchhike his way
to Oregon.
Along the way, he gets picked up by Eddie,
a murderous maniac who's dying of cancer and
just escaped from a mental ward.
Naturally, the two form a friendship, learn
about life, and give Oscar-bait performances
that involve a lot of screaming, squealing,
and super sappy discussions.
"And you want me - and you want me to brush
my teeth?
You want to brush your teeth now?"
In between the conversations about God and
the gags involving an overweight prostitute,
Belushi and Goldberg's eccentricities keep
piling up until you can't help but lose your
mind.